marina rodriguez is being held until she
is sent back to las vegas to face murder
charges
investigators say they are relieved she
was taken into custody so quickly
multiple law enforcement sources
confirmed 35-year-old samantha
moreno-rodriguez was arrested at this
motel near i-70 in peoria in north
denver
early this morning this morning at
around 6 a.m
members of the fbi's apprehension team
in denver took her into custody police
say she left san jose california with
her son liam two weeks ago
his body was found on a hiking trail
near las vegas last month
he was referred to only as john doe
until he was identified yesterday
while the outcome is heartbreaking
there's a sense of closure that liam
houstead will no longer be referred to
as a john doe authorities issued a
nationwide arrest warrant on monday
saying moreno rodriguez had been spotted
on interstate 70 in grand
junction investigators tracked her to a
denver motel on may 31
where she checked in by herself they are
trying to confirm where she was over the
past
week investigators would not say
specifically what led them to this motel
and they are currently in denver
interviewing marina rodriguez
hoping to determine a motive the entire
department specifically my detectives
myself
it's emotionally draining working a case
like this
being able to have closure
and identify liam was very important
and now that we're able to make an
arrest on this case
is extremely gratifying motel guests
were shocked to find out the details
about what happened
well man i hope she gets what she
deserves because you know children's are
innocent you know that i mean
you know it's not the father came into
this world you know what i'm saying but
you know
i hope she gets what she deserves you
know investigators say marina rodriguez
was with an unidentified man when she
was arrested this morning but they say
they are confident
he has no involvement in liam's death if
she waives extradition she could be back
in vegas by the end of the week
in denver deborah takahara